HOW MUCH MORE DIFFICULT DOES IT
MAKE IT FOR YOU?
>> WE’LL JOIN IF NECESSARY.
THAT WAS GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA
RICK SCOTT ON THE SCENE.
WE’RE JOINED NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THIS HORRIFIC DAY.
WHAT CAN WE LEARN FROM WHAT WE
KNOW SO FAR?
AND CAN THESE SCHOOLS REALLY BE
SAFER IN THE FACE OF THESE
THREATS OF MASS SHOOTINGS?
GENTLEMEN, IT’S GOOD TO SEE YOU
ON ANOTHER AWFUL NIGHT.
MARK, LET’S START WITH YOU.
YOU’VE BEEN TAKING THIS ALL IN
TODAY.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, LAURA, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THIS SINCE COLUMBINE, IT
SEEMS THAT PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE
GRAPPLED WITH SECURITY IN A LOT
OF WAYS.
THEY’VE COME UP WITH A LOT OF
SCENARIOS, BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE THINGS THAT ARE COMING
UP.
AND ONCE AGAIN, GUN CONTROL
COMES UP.
ONCE AGAIN, MENTAL ILLNESS.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO STOP MENTAL
ILLNESS.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO GET RID OF
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
WE CAN HARDEN THE TARGET.
WE CAN LOCK DOWN SCHOOLS.
WE CAN HAVE METAL DETECTORS.
WE CAN MAKE THE KIDS SAFE SO THE
SHOOTER JUST CAN’T WALK INTO THE
SCHOOL ANYTIME HE PLEASES.
AND THAT’S WHAT HAPPENS EVERY
SINGLE TIME IN ONE OF THESE
SHOOTINGS.
>> I WAS AT MY KID’S SCHOOL
TODAY AND IT WAS SO WEIRD
BECAUSE I WAS BUZZED IN.
EVERY TIME I’M BUZZED IN TO A
SCHOOL TO VISIT MY KIDS, I
ALWAYS THINK ABOUT THESE THINGS.
IT’S EASY TO GET INTO MOST
SCHOOLS.
YOU CAN KILL A SECURITY GUARD,
THEY FORCE SOMEONE TO BUZZ YOU
IN, THEN THEY’RE IN.
WHAT CAN YOU DO?
YOU CAN’T TURN A SCHOOL INTO A
PRISON.
AND SO THEN PEOPLE GET LOCKED
INTO CLASSROOMS.
AND IS THAT A GOOD IDEA GIVEN
THE FACT THAT THEN YOU’RE A
TARGET IN A CLASSROOM?
I’M NOT AN EXPERT IN THIS.
YOU ARE, RANDY.
>> YOU SAID IT VERY WELL, THAT
WE CAN’T MAKE THESE SCHOOLS INTO
A PRISON.
HOWEVER, WE CAN TARGET HARDEN.
THERE’S A VERY WISE MAN THAT
ONCE SAID, "IF IT’S PREDICTABLE,
IT’S PREVENTABLE."
AND UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE NOW
FOUND THAT SCHOOL SHOOTINGS ARE
PREDICTABLE.
SO WE HAVE TO DISCOVER THE WAYS
THAT WE CAN TARGET HARDEN THESE
SCHOOLS AND AT LEAST GIVE THESE
CHILDREN AND TEACHERS AND STAFF
MEMBERS A CHANCE.
THERE’S CLEARLY A CORRELATION
HERE THAT WE HAVE SEEN TONIGHT
THAT THERE WAS -- BECAUSE OF
TRAINING, MANY, MANY LIVES THAT
WERE SAVED.
SO THAT’S A POSITIVE.
BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT A WAY TO
PREVENT WHAT IS PREDICTABLE.
>> MARK, LET’S GO BACK TO YOU
ON THIS.
WE FOUND OUT THAT HE WAS DENIED
ENTRANCE TO THE SCHOOL CAMPUS
NOT SO LONG AGO WHEN HE WAS
CARRYING A BACKPACK.
HE HAD REPORTEDLY MADE THREATS,
SOME IN JEST, SOME PERHAPS NOT,
AGAINST STUDENTS.
HE WAS SOCIALLY OSTRACIZED.
HIS MOTHER DIED LAST YEAR.
HE WAS AN ADOPTED YOUNG MAN.
HE HAS FAMILY IN THE AREA,
OBVIOUSLY.
BUT HIS MOTHER DIED.
HE FOLLOWED THE IRAQI RESISTANCE
ONLINE AND FIGHTERS.
SOCIAL MEDIA OF HIM WITH VARIOUS
KNIVES, VARIOUS GUNS, ASKING
ABOUT LONG GUN BACKGROUND
CHECKS, PARTICULAR AMMUNITION.
HE WAS GETTING READY FOR
SOMETHING.
>> WELL, THESE ARE CLUES.
AND THERE’S A THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT PEOPLE CAN NAME RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE WATCHING THIS SHOW OF
YOURS RIGHT NOW THAT SAY HE FITS
THAT PROFILE.
SO IF WE CAN PROFILE AND WE CAN
ACTUALLY TARGET THESE PEOPLE AND
ACTUALLY NOTIFY SOMEBODY, IS
THERE REALLY AN AGENCY THAT’S
GOING TO DO ANYTHING?
ON SEAN HANNITY’S SHOW, HE
BROUGHT UP RETIRED COPS AND
RETIRED MILITARY BEING ON
CAMPUS.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT HE’S SAYING,
BUT I DISAGREE.
I THINK YOU NEED TO MAKE SCHOOL
SECURITY A SPECIALTY.
YOU NEED TO MAKE IT A SPECIALTY
JUST LIKE TERRORISM.
YOU NEED YOUNG OFFICERS THAT ARE
MOTIVATED IN THE BEGINNING OF
THEIR CAREER THAT ARE SHARP AND
REALLY DEDICATED TO THE LONG
RANGE IN BEING IN THAT TYPE OF
PROFESSION IN SCHOOL SECURITY
BECAUSE OUR YOUTH ARE SOME OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY AND YET IT SEEMS THAT WE
SECURE THEM THE LEAST.
>> RANDY, BACK TO YOU.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THEY KNEW HE
WAS VERY TROUBLED -- AND THERE
ARE A LOT OF KIDS THAT ARE
TROUBLED.
A LOT OF KIDS THAT COME FROM
BROKEN HOMES THAT SEEM TO HAVE
ANGER, OSTRACIZED.
HE HAD VERY FEW FRIENDS
APPARENTLY AT THE SCHOOL.
WE HAVEN’T FOUND ONE FRIEND OR
ACQUAINTANCE OF HIM.
SO, GIVEN THAT THEY KNEW ALL
THIS ABOUT HIM -- I’M NOT SAYING
THEY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN HE WAS
GOING TO SHOOT, BUT IS THERE ANY
INTERVENTIONS THAT YOU CAN DO
EITHER AT THE HOME WITH HIM THAT
COULD HAVE PREVENTED THIS?
HE WAS EXPELLED FROM THE SCHOOL
FOR OBVIOUS REASON.
>> ONCE THE AUTOPSY OF THIS
INDIVIDUAL IS DONE, A
PSYCHOLOGICAL AUTOPSY IS DONE,
THEY’LL DISCOVER THERE WAS A
NUMBER OF KEY FACTORS THAT SET
RED FLAGS UP ALL OVER THE PLACE.
NOTHING HAPPENS IN A VACUUM.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ALREADY
HAVE SPOKEN THAT KNEW THIS GUY
HAD PREDILECTIONS FOR VIOLENCE
AND HE WAS MAKING THESE
COMMENTS.
HE WAS SHOWING BASICALLY I THINK
HIS CARDS IN ADVANCE.
BUT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT MARK JUST SPOKE
ABOUT.
AND ISRAEL IN THE ’70S DEALT
WITH THE SCHOOLS BEING TARGETED
BY TERRORISTS.
AND THEY LIVED THROUGH
UNFORTUNATELY THE MURDERS OF A
NUMBER OF SCHOOL CHILDREN.
AND THEY HAVE STOPPED IT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, LAURA, WE CAN
TOO.
>> MARK, FINALLY ON THIS, THE
AR-15 LOOKS LIKE IT WAS HIS
THAT WAS INVOLVED IN THE SAN
BERNARDINO SHOOTING, SANDY HOOK,
THE PULSE NIGHTCLUB.
YOU ALREADY SEE THE PUSH ABOUT
RE-EXAMINING THE AR-15.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
WEAPON.
ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR FIREARMS
IN THE UNITED STATES.
BUT THAT CLEARLY IS BEING
TARGETED BY THE ANTI-GUN FOLKS
TONIGHT.
>> WELL, IT’S CALLED THE M4
PLATFORM AND IT’S BASED ON THE
AR-15.
AND YES, THERE’S A LOT OF THEM.
AND MOST OF THEM ARE USED
LEGALLY.
IF A SUSPECT CHOOSES THAT WEAPON
AND YOU TAKE THAT WEAPON AWAY,
THEY’VE BEEN MAKING WEAPONS
SINCE ABOUT 1908 THAT ARE
AUTOMATIC FIRED WEAPONS THAT CAN
DELIVER JUST AS MUCH FIRE POWER
AND ALMOST AS FAST AS AN AR-15.
IN THE HANDS OF A COMPETENT
PERSON, YOU DON’T EVEN NEED
THAT.
YOU NEED SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
-- ALMOST AN ANTIQUE WEAPON TO
DO THE SAME AMOUNT OF DAMAGE.
SO IT’S IN THE HANDS OF A
SKILLED PERSON.
AN AR-15 MAKES UP FOR THAT A
LITTLE BIT.
BUT IT IS NOT THE REASON THAT
THIS OCCURRED.
THE REASON THAT THIS OCCURRED IS
NOT ONLY A MENTAL ILLNESS, IT’S
SECURITY, IT’S NOT HAVING A
HARDENED TARGET, AND ACTUALLY
NOT ANYBODY PAYING ATTENTION TO
ALL THE FLAGS.
>> WELL, THANK YOU, GENTLEMEN,